- Today we remember and
celebrate the friends
who weren't just there for
us during the good times.
- But were also there for the
bad ones.
- To you, we say thank you.
- Thank you.
- For holding my hair back
as I puked in the toilet
and on your shoes a little bit.
- For letting me borrow
your jacket for five years
without you knowing.
- For helping me move
that dead body before anyone
could see.
- For that time when you
shared your fake ID with me.
- For loaning me money
when I needed to buy
shovels to dig that hole.
- Is anybody else hearing this
guy?
- Today we honor you.
- For blocking creepy guys
from talking to me at the club.
- For helping me build
a shed over the hole
so nobody would look there.
- Do you hear that, or is it
just me?
- For taking my phone away
when I started drunk-texting
my ex's new girlfriend.
- Seriously?
- I mean it's not like I'd kill
anybody,
but this dude,
he was trying to cheat at
checkers.
- For only posting pics
where I look good too.
- So are we just gonna act
like it's not happening?
- I'm saying, man, board games
is life!
So if you try to cheat
me out of a board game,
you're trying to cheat me out of
life!
- For that, we say thank you.
- Thank you.
And if you ever tell anybody
what you know about me,
just remember, I know your
secrets too.
- Happy Friendship Day.
- No snitchin'.